and now last week tonight asks how is
this still a thing this week Columbus
Day how is this still a thing America
has a lot of solemn holiday traditions
from saluting the quiet dignity of the
Irish cloud and celebrating our birth as
a nation to just spending quality time
with family at Thanksgiving but next
week brings perhaps the strangest of
American holidays Columbus Day which
brings with it the beloved annual
traditions of GZ local commercials in
1492 Columbus sailed the ocean blue to
celebrate mattress depot and Americans
turning up to an unexpectedly closed
post office and going oh yeah it's
Columbus Day this proud holiday
commemorates the landing of Christopher
Columbus in the Bahamas in 1492
beginning a long tradition of obnoxious
white people visiting Caribbean islands
and acting like they own the place in
school American children learn about
Christopher Columbus's life of course
what they tend not to learn are the
parts of Columbus's life where he
kidnapped Native Americans and sold them
into slavery had his men sliced them to
pieces and through disease and warfare
killed roughly half the population of
Haiti but in fairness none of that
rhymes with in 1492 nevertheless
Columbus became famous for his
discoveries specifically the discovery
that you can discover a continent with
millions of people already living on it
that had also been visited by Vikings
around 500 years earlier in fact many US
states and cities no longer recognize
Columbus Day raising the question why do
the rest of us still do it sure it's a
chance for Italians to celebrate their
heritage but there are so many other
heroes they could celebrate why not
Frank Sinatra day
he killed no Native Americans that we
know of or Al Pacino days a date Allah
probably start well and Penn is an
overblown parody of itself right ass so
well now his least favorite holiday
commemorates a murderous egomaniac whose
most famous discovery was a case of
getting lost and refusing to ask
directions all of which is enough to
make you wonder Columbus Day how is this
still a thing
[Applause]